you know unfortunately we have seen
issues around the nba
with fans crossing the line somebody
tossed a water bottle
and it nearly hit kyrie as he was
walking
to the tunnel tyler johnson noticed it
and the nets began to point out who it
was in that section
there are cameras everywhere so you're
gonna see
the toss right there it just misses
kyrie this is as the nets were exiting
kevin durant was doing the interview
with michael grady
and security began to converge
and look for the guilty part
and just flat out stupid yeah it's an
absolute shame
and we've seen incidents during this
post season but
it's just a terrible thing to continue
watching and it's going to get you
banned
yep from td guard
[Music]
[Music]
box
watch him fall on the stage
oh is he handcuffed
oh this is
[Music]
yes's coverage of the nets during the
postseason to download now just take out
your phone and scan the qr code on the
screen stay with brooklyn every step of
the way
up in boston they could cancel the
celtics out tuesday night at barclay
center let's get the thoughts
of their head coach steve nash right now
on the team's win tonight
[Music]
is